good afternoon everyone and welcome to
the 2013 sustainability leaders series
brought to you by the Yale Center for
Business than the environment happy
Friday to everyone and hopefully we
don't have another snow filled weekend
here in New Haven Connecticut like we've
had recently as I said this talk is
brought to you by the Yale Center for
business environment in partnership with
the GE foundation and will be broadcast
simultaneously through the Yale's
YouTube channel the sustainability
leaders series brings thought leaders to
campus to speak and engage with students
and faculty about the challenges and
opportunities of implementing
sustainability within their respective
organizations welcome to those of you
both in the audience here and online
today we are quite pleased to host a
presentation and panel discussion
entitled geo technology and the future
of sustainability this is the
culmination of a two-day conference here
at Yale organized by the Yale climate
and energy Institute which from what I'm
hearing has been just a fantastic
experience for everyone involved this
discussion will feature Rebecca Moore
engineering manager a Google Earth
outreach and Earth engine and three of
Yale's finest professor Karen Seto
professor Walter Jets and professor dana
tomlin I'm gonna introduce Rebecca and
then provide a little bit of detail
about the format for today's discussion
and then we'll get started so Rebecca
Moore is a computer scientist and a
longtime software professional at Google
she conceived and leads Google Earth
outreach program which supports
nonprofits communities and indigenous
peoples around the world in applying
Google's mapping tools to the world's
pressing problems in areas such as
environmental conservation human rights
and cultural preservation Rebecca has
also initiated and leads the development
of Google Earth engine a new technology
platform which supports global scale
monitoring and protection of the Earth's
environment
Rebecca received her a bachelor's degree
with honors from Brown University in
artificial intelligence with a master's
degree from Stanford University her
personal work using Google Earth was
instrumental in stopping a logging of
more than a thousand acres of red word
redwoods in her Santa Cruz mountain
community the format for this discussion
is going to be I'm going to invited
Rebecca up she's going to
for a period of time then each of our
own experts from Yale is going to give
brief presentations we'll have a
discussion between the entire panel and
then we'll open it up for Q&A to the
audience so please join me in welcoming
Rebecca to Yale thank you very much and
thank you to the Yale Center of
Environment for hosting our Google team
it's been a really fantastic two days
Yale is the first University with whom
we have done an intensive two-day
on-campus workshop there's amazing
environmental science going on here it's
been it's it's a great honor so when we
talk about geo technology there's kind
of an experiment going on right now that
started back in 2005 when Google Earth
and Google Maps first came out and it's
you know what happens when you put in
the hands of the world the most
realistic accurate comprehensive replica
of the planet that has ever existed
before we have more than 20 million
petabytes of satellite imagery in Google
Earth I mean it's billions of megabytes
of satellite imagery we have almost a
hundred million kilometers of Road data
we have 3d terrain and we give that to
people in this very easy to navigate
experience so when Google Earth first
came out
most people were kind of like okay I can
look at my home I can spy in my
neighbor's backyard from space maybe
figure out where to go backpacking but
you know what else can I do and it turns
out that there are amazing applications
of Google Earth to many issues of
sustainability and so I thought what I
would do is is take you on a little bit
of a guided tour of some of the things
people have done first with with who
will earth
and actually before I do that one way I
think about it is we're entering this
new era of geo literacy right more than
a billion people using Google Earth more
than a billion people using Google Maps
part of our motto is seeing is believing
you know making the invisible visible
show people don't tell people some of
the issues that I've encountered
actually personally as as an
environmentalist are that there are
fundamental disagreements about the
basic facts of an environmental
situation on the ground so if you can
eliminate those discrepancies and
understanding you can sometimes make
more progress so here we are green hall
but let's try going somewhere
interesting so when I mentioned when
Google Earth protocol
somewhere is not croon all okay sorry I
didn't didn't mean to be insulting but
yeah when when when Google Earth first
came up we're getting all this imagery
every day one of the common questions
people ask us is how often do you update
your imagery and the answer is well it
depends where you know because we're
updating it every you know somewhere
almost you know every day but we're not
looking at the imagery but sure that
lots of other people are looking at the
imagery and when we publish new imagery
people look at it so one interesting
thing happened people are making
fundamental discoveries about the
natural world using the virtual world of
Google Earth so this is a oh yeah lights
down would be great
thank you for that suggestion this right
here is a fringing coral reef off the
coast of Western Australia that was
actually discovered using Google Earth
it was discovered by a environmental
scientist working in Western Australia
he said when he did that can you see
that better he said he said he felt like
a bloody desktop Darwin right being able
to being able to make this discovery
using Google Earth but it wasn't just
sort of charming it turned out that that
area was about to be subjected to an oil
and gas permitting process and
exploration and that area was very
remote there no roads there people were
not aware of that delicate rare type of
coral reef so that discovery that
virtual discovery actually made a
difference in terms of stopping that
process back closer to home the group
Appalachian Voices was trying to raise
awareness of the more than four hundred
mountains that have been blown up in
West Virginia Kentucky and so on to
produce electricity it's a very
difficult problem to understand without
looking at it on the ground and you're
not or without seeing it from the air
and you are not allowed to go on the
ground to visit these places they asked
if we could help them create a virtual
guided tour of some of these blown-up
mountains so this for example is one a
former mountain almost 800 vertical feet
removed and by looking at this you can
actually start to tell a story this is a
sludge pond that is being held back by
an earthen dam and at the base of that
dam is an elementary school these dams
are known to fail so they've used this
tool to raise awareness in the halls of
Congress about the
environmental implications of these kind
of situations just take you to one more
place here see if this will work this is
another mind site
stop that but they were trying to raise
awareness and get signatures on a
petition and within I think was ten days
of posting this they had more than
13,000 signatures from every state in
the u.s. they also wanted to they did a
very innovative Google Maps application
because they wanted to connect people to
their personal use of mountaintop
removal coal and does anyone know the
zip code here zero six five one one so
you go to this site and many people
think unless they live in Appalachia
they're not connected to mountaintop
removal Connecticut light and power does
that sound good
oh is all right okay so we can redo that
but just for the sake of argument what
they do is they reach into a database of
the power suppliers and where that
electricity is going and you literally
can find out here
what mountains were blown up in West
Virginia when you turn on your light
switch thank you so that is interesting
in terms of connecting people to their
personal impact
a Yale professor one of the other things
we're finding is often local communities
indigenous communities rural communities
in the developing world they know a lot
about what's happening on the ground in
certain places where for example animals
are being poached where illegal logging
is happening but many of the scientists
and nonprofits we've talked to say when
we try to show them a 2d map and we say
show us where these things are happening
they can't make that mental connection
from the real world to that 2d map but
when you show them Google Earth they say
oh this is yeah this is where the
elephants go in the spring this is where
they're getting poached here's where the
illegal traps are and here's a project
that Yale is doing this is an example I
think the image is getting cut off of
working with a local community in South
America I think it's professor Rob
Bayless from the trapeze here but this
is let's go to this part of the planet
they actually
here
yeah they wanted to get a sense of the
fuel wood extraction or where people in
the local community were going to take
fuel wood so with people's permission
they wore satellite tags and their
tracks were captured here you can see
this and this is helping can you see
these different color tracks hardly let
me zoom in a little closer here the idea
is to get a better understanding of how
far people are going to collect fuel
would you see this is it coming out
there yeah so these are kind of
innovative I think techniques of how
people are using this high-resolution
imagery 3d terrain to study some of the
issues of sustainability there's an
indigenous Oh actually here's one other
thing I'll show you there are climate
refugees now because of rising sea
levels there's actually an island in
Micronesia called Pouliot
I hope you're not getting dizzy from the
flying as you can tell this island is
rather low in elevation the community
who lives there have noticed that
they're going underwater they need a new
home believe it or not they have used
Google Earth to help find a new home
when they interviewed the elders to say
what should we look for he said some
place with a mountain
and so again very surprising using
Google Earth they found a new home and
this is where they are now moving it
turns out it has the same breadfruit and
has the it has the the same type of
climate and so on that will sustain them
yeah so there's an rising movement for
payment for ecosystem services including
compensating local communities for being
good stewards of the resources in there
under their jurisdiction there's a
project we've been doing with an
indigenous tribe on carbon in their
forest and I'd like to show you that now
today two places on the planet that are
is also based on the training we went
there and we very perfect party one
about the time where most advanced at
the end of today when inserting Android
handheld devices or cell phones into the
data collection process for carbon
measurement because if saying you're
going to reduce before taking and then
that way reduce carbon emissions
using Google Android so some grandkids
to bring together all the voices they
can participate in a dialogue
Oh
so I'm I'm gonna just do a few more
things that's that was about
geovisualization when you have massive
amounts of imagery for the planet data
for the planet how can it support
decision-making and better understanding
with visualization the the last section
is I'd like to talk about and this
really involves our work with Yale to a
significant degree on new technology our
team has developed called Google Earth
engine for global scale environmental
monitoring and it came from the
realization that the earth is not static
as many of you know it's actually
changing dramatically deforestation
climate change resulting in many changes
on the Earth's surface
these can be monitored from space but
it's a tremendous amount of data but
scientists came to us and asked us if we
would help them in particular first use
case was forest monitoring global forest
monitoring deforestation monitoring in
particular because it's a serious
problem causing a tremendous amount of
greenhouse gas emission there's actually
a protocol called read under
consideration for an international
climate treaty it's a massive amount of
data kind of a Google scale problem and
there was no existing solution for
global forest monitoring and a number of
institutions came to us asking for us to
contribute so some of the challenges
that we learned about are that the
amount of data involved with doing for
example remote monitoring of parts of
the Amazon can be petabytes of data the
the algorithms that are involved the
science exists to do analysis of this
environmental data but it hasn't been
applied at scale it's often locked up in
fine institutions and ivory towers it
doesn't get into as broad operational
use as it can and then once you have the
data and the types of science that can
extract meaningful information from that
environmental data you need massive
computing in order to handle other than
small regions and that's where cloud
computing can play a role so when people
to us with this request we don't just
want to look at the data and Google
Earth the maps we want to do analysis on
it we thought while it's very much
within Google's mission to to do this
sort of thing so here some of the points
but basically we wanted to help
turbocharged science right and and bring
environmental monitoring to a much
broader scale we built the first version
of Google Earth engine which you can
think of as a platform that has an
unlike Google Earth and maps which are
more static Google Earth engine has a
daily feed of imagery coming in from a
variety of sources with lots and lots of
computers and Google's data centers
they're all doing YouTube they should be
doing environmental monitoring in my
humble opinion and then giving an
interface to two scientists well
YouTube's okay a little youtubes ok
anyway two scientists who can put their
methodologies on the platform so this is
probably obvious to many of you who work
with so-called satellite remote sensing
data but you know there are there's a
huge treasure trove of images and other
scientific measurements that are being
collected from space going back more
than 40 years there's been tremendous
systematic observation of the Earth's
surface but that data has been typically
on tape and government archives it has
not been online and available for
scientific analysis what we've done with
Google Earth engine we've started with
the Landsat catalog which is the longest
continuous observing mission and brought
essentially all of that historic catalog
online into Google Earth engine and made
it available to scientists for doing
analysis when you have all that data and
it goes back in time and you have the
ability with Earth engine to do things
like remove clouds remove gaps create a
seamless picture of a planet over a year
you can make things like what you're
gonna see next this is Las Vegas over
the past 25 years
it's it's it's an animation it's playing
it's gonna play four times but what you
can see is the growth of Las Vegas over
the last 25 years and the concurrent
changes in Lake Mead that animation is
not live but it will be soon
and then I wanted to focus on the kind
of applications that our science
partners are building I'm going to focus
on forests you're gonna hear from other
Yale panelists on some of the other
really exciting areas that that they're
working in class light is an annual
deforestation forest degradation package
that by Greg as owner of the Carnegie
Institute for science we're working with
a Brazilian institution Amazon they were
the one who originally approached us and
said we're trying to monitor the Amazon
but every month an issue a bulletin of
what has happened that month but by the
time we finished processing the data
weeks have gone by it's too late you
know the illegal loggers have moved on
to another place well we've now brought
their algorithm into Earth engine as of
last June this is the June bulletins for
the Brazilian Amazon Earth engine is now
systematically monitoring the Brazilian
Amazon and this is an example of the
kind of bulletin they issue and I'm just
highlighting their comment and there was
that with running this on Earth engine
now it will reduce the time for
processing of analysis and dissemination
of data and reach half the time that it
used to take which they translated
literally into hectares of forest that
will be saved because instead of issuing
the report at the end of the next month
you know they can issue it just a few
days after the close of each month and
they can actually intervene meaningfully
in the activities that are causing that
deforestation and now that is being
actually transferred to other countries
closer to home
we're losing forests in Colorado working
with Matt Hansen actually Al Gore came
to us he said this is a vengeance thing
of yours can you apply it to Colorado so
you know working with Matt Hansen we did
and this is showing pine beetle damage
and fire damage
in in Colorado we are all about having
all of this be accessible and ubiquitous
and so here is the the lead red
negotiator for the government of Mexico
running a forest analysis on his iPad
the last point I wanted to make about
the platform is the reason we can do
this global scale analysis efficiently
is we take advantage of parallel
computing we take the area you want to
analyze which could be all of Mexico or
the whole world we split it up into
pieces we farm each piece out to a
different computer in our data centers
each one does its part of the analysis
and then we stitch it all back together
automatically this is all part of the
magic that Earth engine that any any
scientific algorithm can take advantage
of an example of what we did with that
is to produce the finest scale map of
forests in Mexico it was 53,000 Landsat
scenes 18 terabytes of data it would
have was 15,000 hours of computation
which you you ran on a single computer
would have taken almost three years
maybe that's why no one has ever tried
to do it before but because we ran it on
a thousand computers in parallel we had
the result in less than a day so it
sounds like I'm bragging maybe I am but
the point is that you can ask really
different scale of questions now with
this platform there are things this
platform would not be useful for that
existing platforms are fine for it but
these really big big questions that are
that are global we are now at your
service one last example is the Society
for conservation biology and the
European Parliament are developing
policy around roadless areas because
it's been established that when roads go
into a previously pristine area various
kinds of degradation of the natural
ecosystem follow and so they want to
create policy but to do that you have to
know where roadless areas are so they
approached us and they said you have
Road data you have earth engine could
you create the world's first roadless
area map so we did that here's an
example over I guess I seem to like
Australia today
here's here's the Google Maps Road data
for Australia you can literally see
Perth and Adelaide and Sydney and so on
we brought that into Google Earth engine
and we analyzed we put a buffer of you
know five or ten kilometers from each
road and you end up now with this which
gives you what areas are roadless you
could see the outback here is the first
prototype global roadless area map and
now there's this was presented at the
Rio +20
international conference on
sustainability and now we're working to
iterate on this to make it truly an
instrument of policy so I'll just close
and I probably took the long I'm sorry
but where we're going those algorithms
that were running in Brazil and so on
they're now being scaled up we're
working with a World Resources Institute
and other partners to build the world's
first global forest monitoring system
that would be put in the hands of
nonprofits academia businesses who are
trying to be more sustainable in their
sourcing of commodities basically
everyone would have access to this
living breathing daily picture of the
world's forests and with that I will
stop and just say I'm really excited
about the work that Karen and Walter and
others are doing here at Yale and and
hoping that Earth engine will will help
you guys thank you
so now we're gonna bring up Walter Jets
and I was remiss in thanking the the
conference was also sponsored by the
program in spatial biodiversity science
and conservation so why CCI and the SBC
SBS see so thank you all
thanks a lot
and
I'm a faculty here in ecology and
evolutionary biology the old building
just next door
and we work on biodiversity questions
are involved in that that Center that
you just mentioned there's quite a bit
of biodiversity research going on here
at Yale and I think this follows nicely
up on on Rebecca's talk
we are losing biodiversity every day
we're losing it locally as forests
disappear as climate changes here and
there but we also lose it sometimes
globally we start to lose species
globally you know all about many famous
examples of global extinctions and local
extinctions sometimes can be reverted if
we bring the species back into place
it's actually often the global
extinction so we should be really
worried about because we may be losing
the opportunity to use a species for
health benefits or for quality of life
benefits we may lose a beautiful species
to look at for next generations for for
forever take 100 million years for that
something like that to come back now by
this these changes to biodiversity these
impacts they all have their explicitly
spatial right they all have spatial
component only if you know how impacts
such as deforestation and the occurrence
distribution of biodiversity coincide
are you actually able to to understand
what's going on are you able to entrench
late any of these environmental changes
into consequences for biodiversity and
the resulting consequences in terms of
ecosystem services or direct services
for humans for humans into into anything
tangible it's only then can you actually
get active now it is absolutely
fascinating to see the wealth of
environmental information and now thanks
to tools like Google Earth engine of
information about the change in inter
meter scale and and day-day resolution
almost
and now I think with this big
environmental data big data in
environment dictator global dictator we
are really challenged now to see how can
we use that wealth of information and
and use it for biodiversity conservation
and for understanding the impacts where
they occur and what we could do about
them so here I'm going to just demo for
a few minutes something that we've been
working on for the last a few years
thanks to funding from NSF and very
dedicated support from the Google Earth
engine team over in in California and
also a small grant we received from them
via super super privileged to have been
able to work with them and we got some
really great people on this team misses
work also with Rob chorionic at the
University of Colorado Boulder and what
this tool does currently mapping
life.org a map of life is the the name
of the project it allows you to to look
at species distributions worldwide so
unfortunately we bought by far not as
advanced in our battery information as
we are in environmental information from
any species the sort of detail of
knowledge we have is very limited and
I'm just gonna throw up a species here
that I'm going to show you more about
later and I hope going to work is
intended here for that species the
Reuben sorry Torico that's the sort of
information we have about its global
occurrence it's restricted to the Reuben
sorry mountains and for that species we
don't have any other point or survey
data mobilized the only no experts know
it roughly occurs there and something
similar is the situation for many
species now we can now come back to that
species in just a moment so we can grab
a different species say
one of my
favorite species funded Ekans hornbill
where we have much more data sets
available and again we are in East
Africa here and my favorite species
because Catherine is sitting in the
audience there is doing her PhD on that
species and others and we were actually
radio tracking that bird in the wild and
adding all sorts of information but here
it's a greater wealth of information
there is some survey data for a Kenya
these grid cells here and then they've
point data from other sources and then
various range Maps so that's a little
bit now I could show you thousands of
maps they're about 30,000 species in
there right now that usually look more
like that first pieces that I showed you
and for some others we have thousands
and thousands of points and it gets very
busy now that's all fun and exciting and
we can now start to use this information
and integrate it with other pieces for
for inference but first of all this is
also an educational tool it really shows
you the the ware of biodiversity
worldwide and there is something else
I'm going to show you just real quick we
can actually use this information and
force a whole group of birds
well let's switch to another group here
for a whole group of amphibians sorry
that was fish or reptiles
that's the amphibians query so this is a
project now that puts at your fingertips
the species lists worldwide we can go
here into South America and a query any
location sorry still with reptiles here
for the sort of species that occurred
there so 110 species so it's the sort of
tool it's a high-tech heat tool that
really goes through these thousands of
maps that we have in there and brings
back information about the species that
it may occur there and then we can click
on these links here and learn more about
the species so it's really a spider risk
discovery tool the what-what can I find
here what species are here type
information and you can look at the
images we can understand which the
pieces are threatened or we can download
that list and for birds this gets much
richer you can go back to East Africa
where we were earlier and to buy
touristy discoveries there for example
in the routing story Mountains and if
I'm clicking the right spot here we
should get into our list there about 670
species recorded for that location so if
you're a vacation or wanting to go there
want the species list up front you can
get it from here or if you're a teacher
teaching a high school there and you
have good internet access you can
actually use this tool to to do
biodiversity discovery with with your
with your students and here we got a
bunch of Torah cows sitting here and we
can follow up on these images but let's
leave that Leo this is kind of where we
are right now and I encourage you to
play around with this but now the more
techie stuff here so I'm here have
called up again that that species from
earlier and actually let's get rid of
that for now
and this is now using Google Earth
technology and this is still a prototype
so anything can happen now but I'm
really thrilled to be able to show this
to you this is really thanks to Rebecca
and Dave tar in particular and the lead
programmer who's just been shouting some
instructions from back there
Jeremy mal'chik the here again that's
that map right and it's kind of cool we
got that right but it's also a bit
disappointing because I actually even
know about that species this is a high
elevation specialist and it's altura
cause of forest specialists and we know
that sort of information for thousands
of species for 20,000 species 30,000
species we can say very clear things
about what sort of habitat they live in
and suddenly we can actually hang hang
on a second didn't the rebecca say
something about forest mapping and one
kilometer resolution or even better what
about these digital elevation models
that you've you've seen so why don't we
join us all that well we haven't been
able to because we didn't have the
computing resources or we could do that
on our own laptop or or desktop computer
after we waited for a while do it for
one species make it happen
now here fingers crossed
thanks to Google Earth technology we are
able to do this on the fly so here we
have for that species pre-selected the
fact that is of restricted to forests
we've got forests selected here and we
have entered its elevation range already
we can click apply this habitat
modification and there we go we get
actually two things and let me just
change the background here so you see
that a little better we get two things
first of all we get a much more detailed
picture of the species actual
distribution and this is calculated at
ultimately 90 meter or a kilometer
resolution and with it we get now an
updated estimate of its global
geographical range size and suddenly we
are going from about a hundred thousand
kilometers earlier this big blob you
remember to something that's much more
closely much closer to the actual
potential range for that species and
it's less than a ten percent of that
other range that we talked about so
suddenly we have this at our fingertips
and it's transparent everybody can play
with that and you can change these
settings here and include
their habitats and you or change the
elevation range and you would get
different results so experts can engage
with that and use that for predictions
and you can repeat that for thousands of
species you can intersect that with
reserves to get to much more
probabilistic quantitative ultimately
one kilometer resolution understanding
of species occurrences pieces presence
in reserves and their potential
protection status and you can repeat
this for different years of Modi's data
so this is using Modi's data that some
of you may have heard about it's really
good about capturing land cover types
and you can repeat this for different
years and one other thing we're starting
to work on now is a tool that would
allow you to assess potential changes
and in some parts of the world you would
really see how this potential habitat
for that species has changed over the
last ten years and that could really
help inform conservation prioritization
and a land management and could will
ultimately also facilitate a species
list tool that I showed you earlier that
will offer much a greater detail where
land managers really can go in and and
and draw a very detailed potential place
for extraction
and get an understanding of the
potential species occurring there so
with that I'd like to leave it but just
sort of give you a taster of the sort of
things that are becoming possible thanks
to these big data geo technology tools
and thanks to Google Earth engine and if
that
well a little everyone my name is Karen
Seto I'm a professor here in the School
of Forestry and environmental studies
the presentations are gonna get
increasingly less high-tech I am a
geographer and a remote sensing
scientist and despite that I knew not to
follow Rebecca Moore with any animations
or any satellite data because you would
be greatly underwhelmed the title of
today's session is geo technology and
the future of sustainability but I
decided to flip that around a little bit
I was asked my understanding of the
panel was that we are going to talk
about our visions for geo technology and
sustainability and it's been about 20
years 21 years since I first
might--might did my first analysis on
remote sensing and did GIS and the field
has come a really really long way I
looked over at dana tomlin because i
read some of his books as a doctoral
student the field has come a really
really long way but I think that we
still have a really long way to go
especially we're really thinking about
planetary sustainability I'm gonna keep
my remarks relatively short but what I
want to do is give some ideas for where
I think the future of geo technology can
go and needs to go in order to address
some of the most pressing environmental
and sustainability challenges at the
planetary scale I'm going to start off
with these two publications these two
studies that were commissioned by the
National Research Council the one on the
left understanding the changing planet
was published in 2010 and I had the
pleasure of serving on that committee
the one on the right was published just
last year called computing research for
sustainability and if we take a look at
the key messages in both of these
reports I think we see a few themes
common themes that are really reflected
in today's panel and certainly in some
of the comments that Rebecca discussed
first I want to just highlight a few of
the key questions that the national
research committee or national research
council committee on our changing planet
identified as what are some of the
he challenges for sustainability and I
want to highlight a few of these so so
the first big challenge was how are we
changing the physical environment of the
Earth's surface
number two was how can we preserve or
best preserve biological diversity and
protect endangered species how and where
will ten billion people live on earth
how will we sustainably feed everyone in
the coming decade and beyond how is the
movement of people goods and ideas
transforming the world and how white
meat how might we better observe analyze
and visualize a changing world so these
were some of the questions that the
committee identified as Grand Challenges
for sustainability in the geographical
sciences so how can geography how can
geospatial tools how can geo technology
help answer these Grand Challenges my
research is on urbanization and so of
course I see those earlier questions
from the lens of how urbanization is
transforming the planet and here I think
that we are really at a really a unique
time in history in that we're living in
a time where we are seeing unprecedented
global change global changes in terms of
the scale of these changes in terms of
the rate of these changes but we're also
living in this unprecedented time of
large scale technology and geo
technology lots of lots of data and I
think one of the big opportunities
moving forward in the next 10 and 20
years is how can we use these
technologies and these data to help
answer fundamental questions about not
only how we're changing the planet which
is I think much about characterizing
visualizations but more towards
understanding why these changes are
happening and what we can do to actually
obviate some of these changes so you can
see in this slide that urbanization is
linked to a lot of the previous
challenges that I showed in the slide
whether it's about agricultural land
loss and the ability to feed 10 billion
people or simply the fact that
urbanization
takes up land and fragments habitats and
leads to biodiversity loss if we look at
the second NRC publication that I showed
in one of my first slides the the
computing challenges this in many ways
really summarizes the the take-home
messages from in that report and the
vision of that committee was that
advances in computing would allow us to
make trade-offs understand complex
systems and their linkages in order to
account for uncertainty and I think this
issue of accounting for uncertainty and
making linkages is one of the areas that
we haven't done so well in geo
technology so far
certainly not in geography not it not at
the global scale we do it at four small
images one image at a time but I think
that's certainly one of the key
challenges moving forward is moving
beyond visualization moving beyond
characterization to understand what are
the trade-offs behind some of the
decisions that we make and how do they
manifest themselves on the planet again
so my research is on urbanization so I
see everything in terms of from the lens
of urban growth and urbanization in 1800
the planet's population only three of
them three percent of them lived in
urban areas by the end of this century
almost 90% of the global planet this
population will live in urban areas so
the most recent estimates from the UN
suggests that we're going to be living
in a planet of about 10 billion people
so we're talking about roughly 9 billion
people living in urban areas and I think
a really fundamental question is how
this transition will change the planet
whether its biodiversity whether it's
how do we feed people
where these people live how they live
will truly fundamentally change
sustainability our concepts of
sustainability and prospects for
sustainability and I think that's where
future geo technology or the future of
geo technology can really go help us
understand why certain pad
the merge as well as understand the
impacts of those changes there is one
little slide that shows some of the work
that we've done in my lab where we
fought we have forecasted probabilities
of urban growth globally going to 2030
and here in this slide areas that are
red indicate high likelihood of becoming
urban by 2030 areas that are yellow
indicate low probability but still
positive probabilities positive
likelihood it might become urban and the
take-home message from this analysis
that we did that was published last year
is that there's a tremendous opportunity
to shape urban environments but there's
a lot of opportunity to shape how cities
will become but we actually don't
understand how decisions at the local
level at the city level at the plot
level at the household level interact
with policies at local national and
international levels Rebecca talked
about the red protocol you know how will
red impact the prices for timber and and
other raw materials and how will that
actually impact where people decide to
live in the types of houses that lay
live in and I think it's these really
complex linkages that geo technology of
the future of geo technology hopefully
can help us understand I'm going to end
with this slide that is my vision for
where I hope geo technology will go in
terms of helping us understand or come
up with some solutions towards
sustainability I think we have to move
away from characterizing the what that's
the visualization that you see with
satellite data with other types of
geospatial data I think we have to move
more into running scenarios from
forecasting where and when types of
changes will occur what types of changes
will occur across multiple scales and I
think here some of the work that Rebecca
and her team are doing it's really
revolutionary because we're able to look
beyond just a city or even a country but
really look at the planetary scale I
think that at the end of the day if geo
technology does not under
not help us understand the linkages or
the underlying process behind the
patterns that we see than we will have
failed because ultimately the patterns
that we see with satellite data with
other types of aerial photographs any
kind of remote sensing data there's
a-there process underlying processes
that create those patterns and if we
want a certain types of patterns to
emerge whether it's saving you know
certain types of species or having
certain parts of the world that are
roadless or whatever it may be we need
to have a better understanding of why
existing patterns have emerged and
making these linkages across scales so I
think we really need to move into an era
of understanding the whys and the how's
and really moving away from the era of
what and ultimately I think what we need
to do better as a community is is as
more integration and coupling across
disciplines for decades remote sensing
science was really I would say locked in
a small community of people like me
pixel pushers people who like to think
about algorithms and all sorts of geeky
stuff like that and I think one of the
exciting things about Google Earth and
what Google is done is really
revolutionized how we think about and
get access to satellite data and I think
that what we need to do now in this next
era is link the people on the ground who
might have local knowledge with
scientists or with local policymakers
from different disciplines to really
think about much more comprehensive
solutions so all in my comments like
that thank you for listening
and with that I'd like to introduce my
colleague Dana Tomlin who from those of
you who do not know is really one of the
fathers of GIS and I just have to say
that it's a really great pleasure to
have him on the panel with us today
thank you to the best of my knowledge
I'm the father of only one son come back
to that moment early as I was coming to
New Haven this morning I took a route
that was a bit different from the one I
normally take it brought me in front of
the Peabody down Whitney Avenue and it
was the first opportunity I had had for
I realized probably a couple of months
now to see the new som building the the
glass tower over there and as I turned
the corner turned right there was a
fellow with his daughter I would say
about four years old
and I wish you could have seen the look
in her eyes as she looked across the
street at the at the glass tower and it
was at that moment I knew exactly what I
was going to talk about this afternoon I
only have a few moments and so I'll
start of course by talking about myself
spent a little bit of time talking about
those around me and if enough time
remains then perhaps saying something
about about you what I want to talk
about is the the twinkle in her eye and
the twinkles and some other eyes that
I've seen yesterday and today for me the
the comparable twinkle was I think
perhaps as an undergrad when I was
challenged by one of my professors to
hope class was challenged to take a week
and go learn some computer programming
this was using basic believe it or not
it was with paper tape to store the the
programs and I wrote a program that
played tic-tac-toe I like to looking
back I like to think of this as a a
three by three roster of
but it truly engaged me when this
program when it got caught it cheated it
took the move that had already been Anna
replaced the O with the X and when it
did that and I say that deliberately
when it did that I knew that I was on my
my career path a few years later this
was in the in the early 70s I found
myself in a situation where the twinkles
in the eyes were in those of my
professors one of whom would later go on
to be associated with a little company
called keyhole another was actually to
two of my classmates went on and found a
little company called Ordaz and at that
time there was this kid who had
graduated four years before us his name
was Jack something or another I don't
quite remember but had something to do
with Redlands California I believe
anyway it was another professor at that
time who when working on a deer habitat
assessment model came up to me and said
surely you can get your computer to see
those long and stringy forest areas from
those short and blobby areas and that
was just what just what I needed just
what we needed to say you bet we can get
the computer to see those spatial
patterns it wasn't too many years later
when up in Greeley I can remember making
a presentation that again involved deer
habitat in this case up at Yale Meyers
the the grid had grown from a three by
three this was all of 25 rows by 25
columns to grid off the the Yale Meyers
area the one that many of you still know
is the old yellow paper maps and I put
together indeed a deer habitat model
presented it to the class and you may
think I'm joking but I'm not
I tell you that my professor started
chuckling I still feel that talk about
motivation it took me all of 10 or 15
seconds to believe that yeah I'm gonna
show you you we're live right so that
was in the oh let's say toward the late
80s the feeling at that time the feeling
of prospect the feeling that we could do
something that was the feeling of power
was largely motivated by the at that
time this is late 70s the opportunity to
stop visiting ycc to stop visiting the
Yale computer center and as Nate 1980
approached to begin doing what we were
doing on the desktop and you can imagine
with the PC and the the the Mac the the
I'll say again that feeling of power was
just palpable toward the mid 80s I can
remember another twinkle in the eye this
was when doing some work with a Canadian
GIS firm and I remember driving down a
road in Montreal and this fellow said
the president of the company said you
know what I want to do seriously I want
to map the world
this is 1985 he said I want to get
aerial photo coverage of the entire
world and within two seconds of that
statement he was driving I was writing
we crashed
never spoke of it again had an
automobile accident in 1990 some of my
students have referred heard me refer to
the 10-10-10 machine talk about
excitement this was to be a GPS device
that was to have accuracy less than 10
meters it was to weigh the GPS to weigh
less than 10 pounds and at 1990 was to
cost less than $10,000 and that was
really exciting it was at that time too
that I got my first laptop it was a
MacBook and I have it here it weighs
about 25 pounds I think it's black and
white and when I say black and white I
don't mean grayscale it was black or
white but talk about excitement I
remember about that time as well doing
some work with another fellow from ESRI
and I remember it distinctly because we
he lived on a boat off Seattle and late
one night he said listen this is what we
want to do we want GIS on the back of an
envelope let me show you I've got this
new software package it's called
Sketchup well look where Sketchup is
today look where look where we are today
in the mid-90s 93 94 the excitement came
from something that will be meaningful
to not many but I think some of you a
package called mosaic I won't say
anymore about it
google it if you want to find out about
mosaic in 2000 what was it well it was
the move from the desktop perhaps to to
web services in 2005 certainly Google
Earth mobile devices but what is it
today well I can tell you that from my
perspective it's it's two things one is
the opportunity to really go a mapless
what I want to do is to be able to walk
outside not have to bring more reality
into the
the lab but to bring more of the lab out
into the the real world and I not only
want to be able to sense what's around
me I want to be able to look over there
and see 1850 I want to look over there
and know something about the radon I
want to be able to walk down the road
and feel the the crime statistics and
not only do I want to be able to receive
these things I want to be able to make
gestures I want to be able to put that
Walmart over there and as I do that I
want the landscape to react and I don't
mean react just by putting a swatch of
red on a piece of paper I want those
trees to squeal
I want a wristband on my hand that gets
tighter and tighter the more I screw up
the environment I want to take advantage
of those same tactile visceral
capabilities that are otherwise applied
in video games
I just got a serious I just got a text
message from my wife as Karen was
talking it's about my son my son is a 22
year old not unlike some of my other
kids around here he's in a very
competitive filmmaking program
his name's Matt Matt just called
screening went over the top phenomenally
great very happy professor said best in
three years has to become a feature that
has nothing to do with my talk I just
thought I'd share that
actually it has it has everything to do
with my talk because this afternoon I've
had the opportunity to see some of my
other kids about whom I know I'm going
to be just as proud in already yeah but
just as proud in several months Google
came here over the past couple of days
and did indeed knock our socks off and I
tell you we truly plan to reciprocate
Thanks
that was wonderful
I'd like to invite all the panelists to
join us on stage and then in the
interest of time I think we'll begin a
bit of Q&A from the audience so can
those and we are live so everyone if you
could raise your hand and one of the
students will bring a mic to you for
questions and you of course can ask
questions of each other if no one fires
away
so I'd like to ask maybe each panelist
as we're thinking and considering you
know what the future is and and big
broad brushstroke said let's just
consider you know how what is the rate
of change here that we're thinking about
you know what might we be able to
accomplish in you know one year or five
years or ten years and you know in any
of the domains that you've mentioned but
I just like to think a little bit about
you know how fast are things moving
today how can I put a number on that
yeah I mean I think we're seeing kind of
not sort of linear evolution but I
honestly think with with the cloud the
advent of the cloud and it's not just
Google's cloud they're other clouds out
there too it's been a really step
function in what's possible and I think
people haven't even completely yet
crocked how they can use that to tackle
those bigger problems so I think there's
going to be this like period of growing
into what's now you can ask an answer
that's gonna be very exciting you know
for us to help participate in and then
of course you know mobile technology the
integration of you know obviously
there's GPS and mobile technology and
it's wireless is going more and more an
internet more and more in the developing
world so I think they're more and more
places you're gonna see where you can
get real life
a real live data from the field that can
be used to inform what's happening in
the cloud in terms of analyzing
calibrating validating and all of that
just a couple of thoughts
so I'm gonna turn that question around a
little bit I wish I'd done that so III
agree I mean clearly the the technology
is moving very fast we are getting I
don't even know how much data whether
it's from NASA's assets NOAA Japan has a
number of satellites I mean that's the
new that's the new mission to Mars is to
launch your own Earth observing
satellites so there are lots of data
coming on board I think the real lag is
actually transforming data raw data
spectral signatures into information and
then the bigger lag is changing from
information to some knowledge and
changes in decision we have now again
Rebecca had the number I don't remember
lots of data
I mean clearly lots of information and
lots of data some of its being
translated into information but we still
that information is not making us make
better decisions I would say at the
global certainly not at the planetary
scale and Here I am hoping just to
follow up on something that Dana said
that this this new generation of folks
in this room people who are using Google
Earth I think that will hopefully change
that that time but I don't see any I
don't see any parallel rate of change in
terms of data versus knowledge well I
would add that I agree with that
bottleneck that's ultimately the the
brains to think about it smart and it's
it's things to events like these here
that this workshop that the brains get
empowered with the skills and ultimately
hopefully down the road there will be
that bottleneck will be smaller than we
think
I'm certainly excited for about the in
terms of technology and my eyes could
opened over the last few years that I
don't I actually from now see this going
gradually I mean we are looking at 30
meter resolution global analyses so not
just data coming in but also the ability
to actually make make sense of that data
up to a point right and then brain more
brain is required but technologically we
deal with it in why not in 3 years 1
meter 2 meter resolution data I why not
potentially even even finer down the
road so perhaps we'll look back and
think about some sort of Murphy's sorry
some Moore's Law of the ability to to
what we finer and finer grain temporary
and spatial data and I think that's what
we should think about work with with 1
meter data in in 2 3 4 5 5 years but
then at some point we actually will not
just run out of brains to to to do
really smart things with us but also out
of we will run out of sensors actually
that's thinking ahead thinking 5 years
ahead
actually the computational limits may
not be so severe anymore it may actually
be the fact that there aren't any it
takes five years for a new satellite to
even even make it up there and bring it
8 or 10 years longer the the
implementation and so feel my eyes
opened about the opportunities and
computational opportunities but then
there will be other things that will
actually be lacking and sometimes on the
road Danna did you want to vicar I'd
prefer not to answer that question I
would prefer to mirror it back as well
and ask ask you you know what are you
going to do with this technology and in
that regard I would only echo the the
comments of another Google geo sort of
guy Michael Jones who a few weeks ago
when I mused with him about some ideas
he said don't come to me with such small
problems and I would say the same thing
same thing to you
just two well off of what you said Karen
but there's a lot of data that's being
collected that that's not only not being
turned into knowledge but people are not
even they're not even looking at it at
all there's this massive pixels coming
in that nothing is extracted from them
at all
and I think part of the reason is it's
been so hard to do that it takes a long
time to do that and sometimes by the
time you do it the information is stale
right and so what I'm excited about is
this idea that we could really actually
have a written a living breathing model
of the planet that is getting refreshed
every minute you know with this data
that's coming in and the data is
accessible for all kinds of meaningful
information extraction and for example a
lot of these satellites are taxable so
uncertain areas on the planet are
changing faster than others or are under
greater threat and deserve a higher
level of monitor but that's not
happening
so what if you could have this kind of
more adaptive system where you know
information comes in that indicates a
course resolution that there seems to be
something going on here we don't quite
know what it is you task a satellite
that does a finer level pass over that
and gets more information right this
kind of thing could exist but to my
knowledge it doesn't exist today so I
agree with my colleague Walter about you
know getting more finer spatial data but
I would also caution the urge to move
towards finer spatial data and and
thinking that if we had just better data
we would be able to ask better questions
and develop better answers and do better
analyses because I think that's
something that I've certainly seen in
the NASA community for a long time that
well we had six bit data and it was 79
meter resolution so 6 bit data means
that you don't get a lot of radiometric
information out of it and the temporal
resolution was very low
maybe the satellites only passing every
28 days so now we're getting satellites
where we're observing you know the same
image is taken every single day we've
got my goodness we've got now not only
8-bit data which is what I used a lot
we've got 12 we got 16-bit data so
you've got thousands of different
possible combinations for each pixel
across multiple spectral bands we're
dealing with much finer spectral
resolution now so it used to be that a
spectral band was very wide and so you
might get one band for the near-infrared
but now you're getting really really
fine bands of information over really
small intervals of the electromagnetic
spectrum and the question that I have is
yes we can store it we can you know
we're in an era where Google can house
it and compute it but are we asking the
fundamental questions that will help us
understand how the planet is changing
and how we can actually change decisions
to move towards transition towards
sustainability
so I just you know I'm thinking
especially that you know there are now
one meter sub meter resolution data and
I don't see the science moving well
significantly ahead in terms of the
kinds of questions that we can ask we
can definitely see the world in a much
more crisper and all of that but what
have we learned about them again
planetary scale types of questions at
the local scale I think that's where the
spatial resolution really buys us all
well I mean I think the examples that
Rebecca showed us are clearly show that
the spatial resolution buys you a lot
there but I think we should remember
there are when we deal with satellite
data there are a number of other
resolutions the temporal resolution the
radiometric resolution the spectral
resolution and on those fronts we've
also gained you know a lot more
information but we need to also move
ahead in terms of the types of questions
that we ask so how do we do that she's
gonna do it right there okay good
glad somebody is in Connecticut thanks
to the public having spent many years in
corporate doing strategic planning
we look at long-term short-term these
kinds of data or questions we've never
really asked ourselves and my and as I
was reflecting on the information
presented here it's how do we make it
more accessible to whether it's the
average person in Hampton Connecticut or
policymakers so that they understand
that there needs to be action from this
and from corporate executives who have I
think practically everyone has a
sustainability officer today but what
does that really mean
as I'm impressed I'm thinking how do you
translate this so that it's accessible
and it leaves academia and moves into a
more usable setting not saying this is
not useful but I'm just I'm just I'm
having difficulty making that connection
well I mean projects like the one I
showed at the very end the global forest
watch that's kind of the idea of that
project is to take all the best
scientists there's some scientists are
really good at you know monitoring
deforestation in the Amazon and others
are good in Indonesia and some are good
and you know whatever and kind of get
all of that and put it under the covers
of a very accessible easy to understand
and interact with system where anyone
can go kind of like I think your
biodiversity system anyone can go and go
somewhere and see what's going on in
that place and see trends and see maybe
policy that's been associated with that
where are their legal logging
concessions I don't even know all the
details but the idea is it would be very
very accessible is that at all the kind
of thing you're talking about
I just think that I'm just not sure who
beyond an Environmental Studies Program
expert who knows of this who's aware
because I think I would have proposed
different possibilities as a strategist
for example and and I'm not sure how
many of my counterparts are even aware
of that of this type of information how
it impacts us globally because we're
doing global planning and then within
government I was I went to a couple of
sessions in Hartford recently and you
know they're talking about issues on
regarding aging and population growth
and so on and so forth granted it's just
for the state of Connecticut but I don't
know if this there might be information
here that can help in that
decision-making I'm not sure you know
you have municipalities making decisions
on on water treatments and and and I
just see a disconnect between what's
being studied and getting to the
individuals who can make decisions an
impact change so I may think this is
where what Rebecca and her team are
doing really is revolutionising that
that time between science and uptake and
I mean I don't know if Rebecca mentioned
it today but I mean what she showed to
earlier this this afternoon is really
some relatively new technology and I
think that probably a year from now I
had you heard of Google Earth before had
you use Google Earth okay so you'd heard
of Google Earth I would imagine in a
year or so time you will probably hear
or know of people using the map engine
or the earth engine I just want to
explain so Rebecca showed a very quick
snapshot of work that she said was being
done by a scientist named Greg Asner
Greg Asner is a former colleague of mine
out in California and he is one of the
world's most renowned remote sensing
scientists who
a fleiss's own place developed his own
sensors to monitor the forests and he
and his team are developing pretty
complex algorithms a lot of pixel
pushing to identify deforestation and
for a long time his algorithms were
again understood by a small subset of
remote sensing scientists who read these
relatively geeky articles interesting
for us but probably not for you know not
dinner conversation you're gonna have
and it's exciting to see that Google
Earth engine and Rebecca's team is
really translating something that again
one of the world's best remote sensing
scientists and force monitoring now it
is being used by a number of governments
and translated into probably an app of
some sort that is really revolutionary
if I could be so lucky that some of our
algorithms get translated that would be
very revolutionary I would say you can't
have you expect a single website or a
single project to sort of cover it all
right but what's what's the cooler is
that is this is empowering in so many
different directions yeah anything to do
with change analysis with land cover
assessment with well listed list is
endless yeah but but connected to to in
stuff about the environment and and by
making it freely accessible and putting
it all at anyone's fingertips you don't
need a huge computer to do this stuff I
think that's really a huge contribution
and then projects can build up on that
we build up on it with piracy translated
I think also in a way that and anybody
can can do something with and interpret
and other people can build yet on that
so it's gonna cascade and that's really
I think the exciting bit here you opened
your remarks by saying I would what I'd
say I will look around yourself I know
most of the faces that are within reach
of you right now talk to him I'm not
saying that each one of those students
is likely to be interested in the
precise concerns that you've described
but I bet those students know another
student who is interested in the
concerns that you described no we talked
about outreach what an opportunity both
ways
I'm mat long second year student here
I'd like to say this is the most
exciting thing I've seen in my year and
a half here by far it's it's really
amazing and and I will get at your
question as well I'm gonna work right to
left my right to left so Walter I am
using one meter data for a forty five
square mile watershed I have a hundred
and twenty-one million data points I I
had a MacBook Pro with eight gigs in it
and just replaced it was sixteen which
Larry and the CEO told me yesterday has
more RAM than their desktop computers
there so we are with our increasing
computing abilities being able to work
with finer and finer spatial scale data
then on to Karen you're right like the
spatial scale has nothing to do with the
quality of the questions in my case I
can see roads that I wasn't able to see
before so maybe you're also right that
it matters more at a local scale than a
global scale
Rebecca it's awesome that we now have
this computing ability way beyond the 16
gigs in my MacBook Pro and I'm
interested in utilizing Google Earth
engine I'm not sure what kind of
algorithms will be incorporated into it
by the time I want to use it
probably not the erosion model that I'm
using currently but the future is open
let's talk okay and then a open mind
that I'm really thin-skinned okay and
Dana I love your Dr Seuss imagination
that you've always brought to the table
and I would love to be able to swipe and
see that Walmart or have the wristband
on my wrist when I screw up and have too
big of a carbon footprint and and you
know I don't think that's all that
far-fetched maybe not today but maybe
not that far in the future with the
Google glasses you'll be able to do that
exactly I was thinking you you should
get the Google glass and and to answer
your question I I've always thought or
at least I've thought for the last year
and a half that I've been here that maps
are great because they can speak to
people who don't speak English or
Chinese or Spanish you know anyone can
look at a map and especially a 3d Google
Earth driven map and PCs are not all
that common even in relatively rural
areas now but even a paper map and you
can convey information without having to
speak the same language and I think
that's that's what really draws me to
mapping and and now mapping is getting
more and more capabilities to convey
more and more problems or solutions and
and so I think this is a really
beautiful thing that's only going to
expand in the near future
hey do you yeah back to the erosion
modeling believe it or not you thought
you were gonna get away with you know
just leaving it that but do you know the
shell stab algorithm anyway where we're
working with the scientists to develop
that which is I believe in erosion
modeling I know heck grass and SWAT and
WEP but I haven't heard of that one
hi I'm Cara Mae I'm a second year here
and I'm gonna thank the panelists for
being here such interesting information
my question is sort of the opposite of
the last one that was asked from the
woman behind me and I apologize this is
an old question that sort of already
been answered by suspect it's still
being grappled with I wonder about
privacy concerns getting this
information getting into the handset of
people that we don't want it to military
concerns etc and I'll a step further
than that
how are those concerns holding back the
work that you're trying to do so if you
I highly recommend you take a look at
the Grand Challenges report that I
mentioned at the very first slide
because one of the challenges that was
identified by the committee was what are
the privacy concerns of mapping citizens
as well as citizen mapping privacy
concerns as well as accuracy issues so
there are actually a several agencies
within the federal government that are
concerned about these issues I won't go
into detail but that is something that's
highlighted there's a whole chapter on
it discusses it I mean privacy concerns
extend all the way to species really
threatened species and that question has
actually come up with map of life a few
times right if you're able to predict at
one kilometer or 30 meter ultimately
grained probability of certain species
interested interesting for trade or for
exploitation occurring you actually run
into into some serious problems and you
may be doing some bad so this is
definitely something that that is
increasingly on our mind and there are
ways to deal with it you you black out
species that are of such concern and
only make it available to to academics
but yeah it's actually something that
even in bio risky science we have to
think about
so I don't know exactly what the gist of
the question is because it's a big topic
privacy but I know for example with with
Google Earth and maps we and things like
Street View we blur out personally
identifiable information but I stepping
back to a bigger question I think
sometimes governments raise certain
issues that that may be under the
privacy banner or whatever and it's in
fact leading to a loss of transparency
of you know their activities so I think
one of the the the benefits of having
more access to information is there is
just more transparency on what's going
on by all the different actors you know
donors are giving a tremendous amount of
money now donor nations like Norway to
government's to enact better policies
and action on the ground for forest
protection but the money sort of
disappears and no one knows where it's
going and it's not necessarily getting
to the ground where the actions are
really the positive actions are needed
to be done so again this is not totally
related to privacy but just there's a
there's a benefit to having more
transparency and some things my name is
Nick I am an undergraduate here and I
wanted to actually start out with a
question that was asked the beginning or
at least an invitation which was um or a
hope that that you know this would be
open to high schoolers and junior high
students as well that we would you know
find ways to sort of integrate mapping
into the curriculum I think that one of
the interesting things I've noticed this
weekend
excuse me Thursday and Friday we're not
there yet
is that I've only seen about three or
four undergraduates here and I think
that's that's telling because you know
from my personal experience gs wasn't a
word I heard until last year and I've
been sort of frenetically
trying to you know speed
a learning curve since then um I wanted
to ask you know I think obviously you
know finding application for it in the
wider world is great but in terms of
Yale you know how do you find you know
like a strong base especially in the
College of of you know integrating GIS
into a curriculum that's a very good
question and it's it's one you've
actually already been talking about a
little bit actually we had a we had a
discussion not to whether you were still
around for that
yesterday afternoon among a smaller
group of educated geo education and how
to to use tools like this or others for
teaching now I think there is something
extremely empowering through tools like
Google Earth engine if you think about
Google Maps or Earth Google Earth
people are already using it teachers are
already using it already in high school
level and that certainly at the
undergraduate level I'm teaching a
conservation class here and I've had
folks use these simple tools but on the
very simplest very simplest and if the
more we make that easier the more I
think professors will be able to use
these tools there's been a large barrier
of entry so far in that these tools
these offline tools you have to like
take a course and we have amazing
facilities so Stacy maples is sitting
there and it's doing an amazing job here
teaching undergrads actual lot of
students GIS but it still it takes
dedication to do that and so I think we
were looking at all sorts of new ways in
which the access to GIS and these sort
of things that we've seen earlier
becomes easier and this is one of the
really promising ones given after that
for me yeah I mean so before I came to
you I was at another school where there
was no Geography Department I'm my PhD
is in geography and unfortunately the US
and many countries geography not in Asia
and not in Europe but in the u.s.
certainly geography education K through
12 is going downhill and there have been
there's another NRC study from about 10
years ago that examines the state of
geographic education and the advent of
geo technology and the uptake of geo
technology is kind of a double-edged
sword because on the one hand a lot of
people are using things like Google Maps
Google Engine Maps MapQuest or you know
I don't even know that's still around
but I feel our understanding the the
power of mapping and you know the
student back there mentioned how fun it
is to map and it was just made me very
happy as a geographer but at the same
time the double-edged sword is that
people think that it's just a technology
and that there's an entire science
behind the maps that you see there's a
lot of I mean there's a lot of math
there's a lot of computer science
there's actually a lot of cognitive
sciences behind there as well psychology
and it's not it's you know what they
make what they do when I say they you
know whether it's Google or ESRI or
these these these softwares that you're
using actually has a lot of science
behind it and so I think that's the
challenge that we run into today for a
lot of universities is how do we you
know and I think this is a question for
administrators is you know how is GIS or
remote sensing your technology moved
away from just being a technology I mean
ironically a few years ago I was on a
panel that consisted of Ivy Lee schools
and my former school in California kind
of elite all elite schools that didn't
have a Geography Department anymore we
all had geography departments but they
were all abolished sometime between the
1940s and 1969 and yet all of these
universities Brown Stanford Michigan I
can't remember vered they all had a GIS
guru like Stace was that all the faculty
said we could not do our jobs we could
not do our science without someone like
that and in fact we need an employ a
team of them but also that we need to
teach the students the science behind
let's see uncertainty and and move
beyond thinking about this as just a
technology so I'm
I do think that it's a double-edged
sword but hopefully having more students
being interested in this technology
might also bring back some of the
science behind it I have it I have
another answer
I want to seduce people into GIS I mean
there's really spatial reasoning should
be part of many disciplines right
whether it's Public Health epidemiology
political science I mean these human
activities take place on a physical
planet and there are realities about
interactions right that that happened in
space and so calling something it's oh
you have to study this thing called GIS
makes it kind of too onerous and some of
the things we're trying to do with with
the new tools that are coming out or
sneak some lightweight GIS into very
familiar interfaces like Google Maps so
that what's the distance from here to
here what you know create a buffer
around something the intersection of
this or that you know there's really
three or four maybe eight types of GIS
operations that basically everyone can
intuitively understand and have broad
applicability so that's kind of what
we're excited about can we bring that
level of spatial reasoning into very
easy-to-use familiar tools and let
people apply them broadly across many
domains that makes sense one of the
ironies though is because we are because
these technologies are so ubiquitous and
so easy to use
we actually there are a number of
studies to show that we are not using
our own spatial reasoning skills right
how often do you think well how how far
is it to get from X to Y well I don't
know let me map it well you could
probably figure it out or the one that I
find interesting whenever I take
students out into the field is they
can't figure out where north south east
or west is and and so I said oh here's
my compass I know it doesn't require any
battery-operated thing but it works and
actually if you look at the where the
Sun is and relative to where we are now
it's remarkable so I mean I think there
are some dangers with relying too much
on the technology as well no there are
no dangers
so with that we'll we'll let this
conversation continue into the night and
thank you
someone will this will wrap up our panel
discussion which culminates our two days
of events here we'd like to on behalf of
Yale I'd like to to thank Rebecca Moore
and her team an amazing team that's come
to us could everybody stand up
yep and let's give them a hand
I've just been outstanding and
co-hosting this event we'd like to thank
the Yale SB SC the yce I the C Bay and
the Yale Center for Earth Observation
for co-hosting this event and we'd like
to thank all of you for attending this
and making this and just a tremendously
exciting event that will have ripples
and reverberations for time to come
Peter we're not done yet
Walter yeah so this all wouldn't
probably wouldn't have happened at all
and certainly wouldn't have happened
this smoothly if it hadn't been for
Peter Christensen a PhD student here at
the Yale and Karen Cedars lab speak that
you know we were here I spoke a year ago
and talked for like three hours
afterwards with Peter and it was so
exciting and it's really he's been
driving the interaction between Google
and Yale for the last year and really
made this whole thing happen hey let's
see everybody join us at the reception